and finally new rule for the sake of
democracy we have to move Halloween move
it far far away from Election Day why
because it's a reminder of everything
conservatives hate fun imagination
paganism walking
gay pride women dressing provocatively
kids demanding free handouts that's
socialism
your public and voters are scared enough
as it is when they hear the doorbell
then think it's one of three things
ms-13 and Tifa or a false accusation of
rape the last thing they need to look
out there and see is black panther think
about the things that angry up the Fox
News base what's the single overarching
message of that network weirdos are
coming for your [ __ ] well that's what
happens on October 31st people dressed
as pimps and hookers walking up your
driveway people in Chains who aren't
Hillary which cackle doorbells that
sound like Hillary
[Laughter]
men dressed as women women dressed as
men adult dresses Harry Potter and
everything is [ __ ] [ __ ] nurse [ __ ]
pirate [ __ ] Pizza rat [ __ ] Bishop
Desmond Tutu [ __ ] Saudi assassin it
never ends
the only thing conservatives like about
Halloween is the appearance of Nosferatu
but I'm telling you Halloween they hate
for socialism they hate the paganism
that the Bible specifically condemns
witches vampires Wizards ghosts you know
all the fun people at the party and then
it also became gay Christmas
how gay how gay is Halloween
it makes West Hollywood gayer
it's like making Utah whiter and then
there's the trap we walk into every year
now I personally don't care if you go
trick-or-treating dressed as 0.01% of
Elizabeth Warren
but the office of scolding justice
warriors has decreed no hula girls no
Indian chiefs no Southern Belles no
Daniel Boone no geishas ninjas gypsies
mobsters terrorists no Cleopatra pirates
offend one-eyed people and you can't
dress there's a hobo because it makes
light of the homeless you can't dress
this Quasimodo cause it offends
hunchbacks you can't can't dressed as an
escaped mental patient at defense Kanye
the sexy Handmaid's Tale costume The
Handmaid's Tale costume has already been
pulled from the shelves and an apology
issued lest someone be offended by the
ironic take on a character that doesn't
exist from a fictional world that never
happened you know not everything that
merely alludes to another culture is
racist or cultural appropriation really
imagine there's no countries it isn't
hard to do Halloween was always fun
because it wasn't PC not being PC is
almost the whole point of the holiday
but now everything has to turn into a
federal case of snowflakes versus humour
and then some cultural studies professor
will go on TV to try to explain his
outrage and Tucker Carlson will look at
them like this
the majority of America is with the
Democrats on the issues they just find
the woke people era tating as hell in a
new poll 80% of Americans find political
correctness to be a problem including 75
percent of African Americans 74 percent
of Americans under 30 82 percent of
Asians 87 percent of Hispanics 88
percent of Native Americans if you're
not a statistician let me break those
numbers down for you nobody likes you
including the so-called marginalized
groups whose feelings you've decided
need protecting because trust me
somewhere right now three clueless white
girls in Texas who are planning to go as
a mariachi band and when they do liberal
Twitter will lose their [ __ ] and the
rest of America will go oh for [ __ ]
sake
when did liberals become the fun police
does anybody remember when conservatives
were the ones with the sticks up their
asses
we went from yes we can to oh no you
didn't
[Music]
[Applause]